and here's the thing about problems
2020 is full of problems parents are
full of pr everyone's got
problems and i was thinking about my
problems the other day and
kelly daniels sent me this phenomenal
text
i was in the middle of reading medical
journals articles
trying to get smarter for this podcast
show
helping me get smarter is a long
treacherous road right it's
a long journey through my thick skull
and i couldn't get past this one problem
i was trying to wrap my head around
like america's got problems like in-laws
have problems and kelly daniel
the oracle that she is sends me a text
and she reminded me of wisdom i learned
in sixth grade
and it was this i was told
that if i had a problem yo he'd solve it
i just needed to check out the hook
while the dj revolved it vanilla iceman
where
are you dude you said you would solve
all of our problems
2020 sucks the world's falling apart we
have
father-in-laws who treat their
daughter-in-laws like garbage because of
the way they look at their because their
face their facial expression listen
ice brother you told me that sometimes
there are girlies on standby waiting
just to say hi but no you've got to
just hit the gas and drive by to go
solve the problems ice we're waiting for
you man we are waiting for you
okay let's go to robert orlando i'm
gonna stop right there